let's say that we've got a position
vector P and it is equal to we'll
represent it as a column vector right
over here to 1 so if we wanted to plot
this and that's what I will do let's
plot it so if we were to plot it that's
my y-axis this right over here is my
x-axis x-axis so if we assume that the
first entry here is the x coordinate 1 2
comma 1 so our position vector is going
to be right over here we could represent
it we could represent it in this kind of
vector symbol right like that
where the tail is at the origin and it's
the tip the head is at that point or we
could say it's really representing this
position right over here on the
coordinate plane now what I want to do
in this video is apply a transformation
to this position vector and the way I'm
going to do it is I'm going to multiply
our vector P by a matrix and then the
resulting product is going to give me
another position vector so what do I
mean by that well I could have a
transformation matrix capital T and
let's just say it is equal to 2 let's
say it's equal to 2 1 negative 1 & 2 so
what happens if I multiply 2 times P
let's do that right over here T T times
P so first let's just make sure that
this that that this is actually a valid
operation that that matrix
multiplication or matrix vector
multiplication is defined here so let's
just look at what T and P look like we
already know what they look like so I'm
going to copy and paste copy and paste
that is T and this is P right over here
so copy and paste and let's see can we
multiply can we multiply a 2 by 2 matrix
times a column vector like this which is
essentially a 2 by 1 matrix well sure as
we know matrix multiplication is only
defined or at least
conventional matrix multiplication is
only defined if the first matrix the
first matrices number of columns number
of columns is equal to the number of
rows in the second Matrix right over
here we see there both of those are two
so this is going to result in a two by
one matrix so this is going to result in
a two by one matrix
now what's interesting about that what's
interesting about that is that this is
another column vector this is another
position vector so you took this vector
P multiplied it by this transformation
vector and we're going to get another
two by one which we could think of as a
position vector which we could plot so
what's essentially happened is is this
this transformation vector has moved has
essentially given this point it has
given us a new point so let's think
about what that is so this first entry
here we're essentially thinking about
we're going to deal with the first row
and the first and the only column really
so let me do it use a color that I
haven't used yet so we're going to think
about this row in this column so is
going to be 2 times 2 which is 4 plus 1
times 1 which is 1 or this is just going
to be equal to 5 and then for the second
entry right over here it's going to for
the second row first column it's going
to deal with the second row here and the
one-and-only column right over here
so negative 1 times 2 is negative 2 plus
2 times 1 which is 2 negative 2 plus 2
is just equal to is just equal to 0 so
now we have the position 5 comma 0 which
is right over here so 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 5 so
we started with this point this this
position vector I guess you could say P
has transformed it to this other
position vector and I guess we could
call this I want we call this P P Prime
so that if you wanted to draw them as
vectors this right over our kind of in
traditional vector form that right over
there is P Prime
this right over here is P this right
over here is P this is P actually make
sure there's a prime and this is P Prime
and the way we got from P the P Prime is
using this transformation matrix